sake made from [ __ ] dough woodcock
[Music] I do
n't like Susumu Sensei's miso. I don't like
something like this, so it's Sugimoto's
product. Everyone is classy. [
Music
] I like it. [Music] No,
I like it.
Also,  Data to make a tab that fell out with all its internal organs Stand underground and
praise it while saying that it must
have been the top [ __ ] ceiling fit top Chita tap Ittabu I think it came
Stutatabutatatabutatto Minute It has
changed a little bit Ogata
Now what did I do?  Don't hit me!
If you run, Ogata will win. I'm not saying that Ogata will win.
[Music]
I gave it to you. It's
Douichi's turn. Let's
eat. After the woodcock, I
'll have some stewed tough meat. That's
enough.